I'm returning my red iPhone.
And this red case.
Now before we get into the specifics of why,
A lot of people, I was actually quite surprise,
In the comment, had no idea that
RED is actually a charity.
And they've been around for quite a while.
Apple has been partnering with them for 10 years,
And this phone, was actually a 10-year celebration
Of working with them.
Apple in total had donated 130 Million Dollars
To the RED foundation.
The entire charity has raised 465 million,
Which make Apple one of their leading donor.
Now I've no idea what the specifics are,
The Percentage of the iPhone sales
Or cases, or how that all works.
Technically, this phone is for charity
And I don't know how much is actually going to RED.
And if you're not familiar with RED as a charity,
It's an HIV and AIDS prevention treatment counselling
And they also have a very specific focus,
On eliminating transmission from mom to child
Which, is kind of powerful.
And here I am, buying a silly iPhone,
For the sake of the color, granted yes,
I did know a portion is going to charity
Which that's absolutely incredible.
But then I'm thinking, now I'm returning it,
So does that mean I'm taking that little bit
Of the percentage away from the charity
That I just technically sort of donated to?
Yeah.
And for a very silly, superficial reason,
And the reason I'm returning it,
Is simply because, I just realize,
That I don't like the color red.
Like, at all.
I like it as, sort of an accented color to things,
But just for a simple color in whole,
So I've been a graphics designer for quite a long time,
So I absolutely love colors,
And the way of different colors can make people feel,
And red does not make me have a very good feeling.
At all.I do not like it.
I was looking at my Instagram feed,
My YouTube thumbnail, after a past couple of days
Of me making videos about the phone,
And it just hit me like
This phone does not actually make me happy.
My Jet Black phone made me really happy.
It still make me happy, and I really like it,
And it's a prefectly great phone.
So this is what I decided to do,
I decided to return the phone,
And then donate the entire portion
Of what I paid for this phone, to RED.
So I think that's a much better use
Of the money I paid for this phone.
I mean, I bought this phone,
So I'll get that money back,
And I'm gonna donate it, to RED. Simple as that.
I just wish I knew what percentage of this
Actually went to charity.
But now at least I know that,
Basically 100% of what I paid for,
Is now going to actually help people.
Sigh. So that's my reason,
On why I'm returning it. It's simply because
I don't like the color.
And it's crazy cause I ran into a bunch of people
Who saw my video and they were so excited
To show me their phone,
'Look I got it!' I was like, it looks good.
It looks incredible.
Also I want to address,
A lot of you guys said, Justine, just get a clear case.
Then that will alleviate the problem
If you want to see the phone's color.
I don't like clear cases.At all.
I've had them before, I've had them in the past,
With travelling, going to crazy shoots,
Random destinations,
I never really know where I'm gonna end up,
From a day to day basis,
I can just tell you that clear cases, get really disgusting.
Stuff get stuck in between it,
And it's trapped there,
So not only are you looking at your phone,
But you're looking at all of the dirt that your phone
Has come in contacted and it's trapped in there.
And it's not a pretty site.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
Or if you guys have a case, that's clear and perfect,
and no dirt gets in, let me know what it is.
Because that's a magical case.
I also feel so bad,
Because I made that video,
And the bunch of my friends was like,
Justine I got the red phone cause you said
it was so cool!
It is cool, I think this is an absolutely,
beautiful phone.
It looks so good, I just don't like the color red.
That's it, everything about it, I love this phone.
You already knew it, I like the phone.
That's nothing new.
I'm keeping the other red case that I got,
And the Apple Watch band because they match
perfectly, so this just didn't make me happy.
So I would much rather take that money that I have,
And hopefully change somebody else's life
And make somebody else way more happy.
Then this phone could've made me
That's it.I'll see you guys later.
Hope you guys have a great day.
I'm gonna now return it now. See ya!
~Preview of old videos~